¡Ya es oficial! El 20 de enero de 2017 es
Donald Trump se convierte en el 45º
presidente de los Estados Unidos,
el hombre más poderoso de la tierra.
En VisualPolitik hemos sacado montones
de vídeos explicando todos los
despropósitos de su programa electoral. Pero la pregunta que nos hacemos hoy es:
¿hasta qué punto tiene poder para
llevarlos a cabo? ¿Qué poder real tiene el
presidente de los Estados Unidos?
Por ejemplo, si Donald Trump se levanta una
mañana y le apetece mandar dos cabezas
nucleares a cualquier otro país, ¿puede
hacerlo o tiene que consultar
previamente al Congreso? ¿es posible que
el Senado o la Corte Suprema frenen esas
deportaciones masivas de inmigrantes que
proponía durante su campaña electoral?
No olvidéis que Estados Unidos presume
de tener una democracia extremadamente
sana donde la separación entre poderes
legislativo ejecutivo y judicial está
bien definida. Este sistema que los
politólogos llaman sistema de
contrapesos sirve para evitar que
algún día un psicópata tomara el
control del país e hiciera cualquier
barbaridad aprovechando el poder que ha
conseguido en las urnas. Sin embargo y aun con eso el presidente
de los Estados Unidos tiene poder para
hacer un montón de cosas por su cuenta.
Y creedme: algunas de ellas os van a dar
mucho miedo.
Hoy vamos a ver todo lo que pueda hacer
Donald Trump sin necesidad de consultarlo
con nadie. Y lo vamos a hacer
junto con mi amigo Xander Snyder.
Xander es uno de los coautores de
Reconsider Media, uno de los mejores
podcasts políticos que hay en Estados
Unidos. ¡Hola Fonseca y un fuerte
abrazo a todos los suscriptores de
VisualPolitik. ¿Existe el botón nuclear?
La respuesta es SÍ, el botón nuclear
también conocido como 'nuclear football' o
botón del fin del mundo existe y se
guarda en este maletín que veis en la
foto.
Y como su propio nombre indica es una
consola con un botón. Cuando el
presidente presiona ese botón,
automáticamente manda una orden a dos
oficiales del ejército estadounidense.
Normalmente dos tenientes que están en
uno de los aviones bombarderos que
albergan una bomba nuclear.
Esos dos oficiales tienen una llave
cada uno.
Si esas dos llaves se meten en sus
respectivas cerraduras a la vez, se
abre la compuerta y se lanza una bomba
nuclear. Y os preguntaréis, ¿existe
alguna ley especial o algún tipo de
reglamento para poder lanzar esa bomba?
Pues no, no hace falta. Tal cual.
Desde el punto de vista legal y constitucional un
presidente puede presionar el botón en
cualquier momento y físicamente el
personal militar tiene que llevar a cabo
la orden y si la ignoran se considera
insubordinación y podrían destituirles o someterles a la ley marcial.
Todo esto viene de la Guerra Fría, el
gobierno de los Estados Unidos se
sentía amenazado por la Unión Soviética,
que podría lanzar una bomba nuclear en
cualquier momento.
En ese caso la Casa Blanca tendría que
reaccionar al momento y no habría tiempo
para tener que debatirlo en el congreso ni
en el senado.
Por cierto, esto tan bonito que
está sonando es la música de No Respect, un grupo de nü metal de Lima en
Perú que nos ha enviado su música.
Si os gusta, encontraréis más
información sobre ellos en los enlaces
de la descripción.
Pero esperad un momento porque todavía hay más.
Imaginad que un día Donald Trump se levanta
y como le caen mal los chinos decide
lanzar un par de cabezas nucleares
contra Beijing.
Pues sí, legalmente puede hacerlo pero no
se saldría de rositas.
Concretamente bombardear China hoy en
día violaría el derecho internacional
y todos los acuerdos de alianza que hay
entre China y Estados Unidos. Eso significa
que el congreso de los Estados Unidos
tendría que exigirle explicaciones e
incluso hacer una votación para elegir
si habría que echarle o mantenerle en
el poder. A este proceso se le conoce con
el nombre de 'impeachment' y no es la
primera vez que se realiza, y si no que
se lo pregunten al bueno de Richard Nixon.
Pero ojo porque no solamente vamos a
hablar de bombas atómicas.
¿Qué pasa con las guerras? ¿Puede Donald Trump
declararle la guerra a otro país?
Vamos a verlo.
Guerra y estado de emergencia.
Para declararle una guerra oficialmente a
otro país
hace falta una votación en el congreso.
Así que no, Donald Trump no puede
declarar una guerra por su propia cuenta
y riesgo. Pero, sin embargo, en casos de
emergencia
el presidente puede enviar tropas a un
país aunque no se haya declarado una
guerra oficialmente.
Aquí tenéis un ejemplo:
Obama recibe críticas de los dos
partidos políticos por no haber pedido
autorización al congreso antes de
ordenar al ejército americano que se
uniera a los ataques contra el gobierno
de Libia. Es decir que si Donald Trump
quisiera,
podría mandar tropas a
Iran por ejemplo. Pero sólo podría
hacerlo durante 60 días después de esos
dos meses tendría que ir al congreso
pedir una aprobación y someter a
votación la declaración oficial de
guerra para poder prolongar la presencia
militar en la zona.
Dicho de otra manera, Donald Trump
podría mandar tropas a otro país pero
sí quiere que se queden más de 60
días necesita someterlo a votación en
el congreso. Pero una vez el congreso ha
aprobado la guerra,
el presidente vuelve a tener el poder
para controlar todos los aspectos de
la guerra.
Eso significa que el presidente puede
ordenar operaciones muy concretas,
acordaos de la captura de Osama Bin
Laden que fue dirigida directamente por
el presidente obama o incluso los
bombardeos de drones que también ha
autorizado nuestro querido amigo Barack.
Pero si todo esto os parece poco
esperad un momento porque ahora vamos a
hablar de la economía.
¿Adiós a los tratados de libre comercio?
En lo que respecta a la economía,
prácticamente todas las decisiones de
política doméstica tienen que pasar
por el congreso, si Donald Trump quisiera
subir o bajar los impuestos tendría que
someterlo a votación parlamentaria.
Lo mismo ocurriría si quisiera
liberalizar un sector o nacionalizar una
empresa. En muchos casos incluso tendría
que enfrentarse al Tribunal Supremo o a
los propios gobiernos de los estados.
Pero de eso vamos a hablar en otro
vídeo. Lo cierto es que donde sí tiene
poder Donald Trump es para hacer y
deshacer los acuerdos de libre comercio
internacional. Y no os penséis que es
ninguna tontería porque las empresas de
Estados Unidos compran y venden cosas en
todo el mundo. Y estas relaciones
comerciales se regulan a través de
tratados entre países.
Muchos gobiernos ponen impuestos
especiales que se llaman aranceles a los
productos que vienen de países
extranjeros. Para evitar esto, las
naciones suelen firmar lo que llaman
tratados de libre comercio.
En norteamérica
tenemos un tratado que se llama el Nafta
y permite el comercio sin impuestos
entre México, Estados Unidos y Canadá.
Como este tratado se firmó hace más
de 20 años, Donald Trump ya no puede
romperlo o al menos necesita hacerlo a
través del congreso y el senado.
Sin embargo hay otros dos grandes
tratados que aprobó Obama pero que
todavía tienen que someterse a la
votación del congreso.
Por un lado está el TPP, que consiste en
crear una zona de libre comercio entre
Estados Unidos, Chile, Perú, México, Canadá, Asia y el Pacífico. Y por
el otro, está el TTIP que
consistiría en lo mismo pero entre
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea. Estos dos acuerdos ya están prácticamente
hechos y solamente falta que se voten en
el congreso. Pero una vez se han
aprobado los tiene que firmar el
presidente de los estados unidos y si
quieres puede vetarlos. Para cuando
llegara este momento
Donald Trump ya sería el jefe del estado
y como sabemos no es precisamente un
gran amigo del libre comercio.
El TPP es un acuerdo horrible, es un acuerdo que
nos va a dar más que problemas. Es un
acuerdo pensado para que China entre
como hace siempre por la puerta de
atrás.
Ahora bien, sólo puede vetar la ley o el
acuerdo en su totalidad. No puede decir
esta parte sí, esta parte no. La ley
estadounidense solo le permite
vetar una ley en su totalidad.
Pero sin duda alguna el área donde a Donald
Trump le gustará utilizar sus nuevos
súper poderes como presidente
es esta:
Inmigración. Aquí está la palabra más
odiada y a la vez más repetida de Donald
Trump durante su campaña electoral.
Sin embargo y por irónico que resulte
apenas tiene margen de actuación en
este punto. Para construir el muro
necesitaría la aprobación del congreso
porque no deja de ser una obra pública.
El único modo por el cual Trump podría
construir el muro por su propia cuenta
se haría si consiguiera que México
pagará por ello y que hiciera la
obra en su lado de la frontera. Es decir
el mundo se levantará en territorio
mexicano. Pero de eso vamos a hablar más tarde.
Lo cierto es que lo único que va a poder hacer
Donald Trump es ordenar al
departamento de seguridad nacional que
ponga las deportaciones a inmigrantes
ilegales como prioridad máxima.
¿Pero sabéis cuál es el problema?
Que Obama ya lo ha hecho antes que él.
Según datos del gobierno la
administración Obama ha deportado a
más gente que ninguna administración
anterior. Es decir que por irónico que
resulte la administración Trump en lo
que a inmigración ilegal se refiere
va a ser bastante continuista de la
administración Obama.
Y la pregunta es, ¿os parece bien que el
presidente más poderoso del mundo tenga
capacidad para tomar tantísimas
decisiones de forma unilateral?
¿No os da miedo que una única persona
pueda decidir lanzar bombas nucleares
contra otro país?
Podéis dejar de vuestra respuesta en
los comentarios y ojo que Donald Trump ya
ha dicho que quiere ampliar su arsenal
nuclear.
Pero eso os lo explicamos en este otro
vídeo. Si quieres echarle un vistazo
haced 'clic' aquí. Y no olvidéis que
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas. Así que suscribiros al canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en
el próximo.